you can't say choisi aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur run légende sur une bonne
grosse partie comme foot comme on les
aime
mais attention pas contre n'importe qui
effectivement j'ai eu la chance de jouer
contre christophe ayral et michel ancel
alors qui sont ces deux personnes vais
gérer vous mais chez lancel celui que
vous voyez tout à droite sur cette image
c'est celui qui a créé yamal il y a
vraiment beaucoup d'années et christophe
héral juste à côté c'est celui qui fait
toutes les musiques du jeu alors autant
vous dire que ce sont deux personnes
vraiment amusant vraiment sympa qui on
voit juste de la bonne humeur
du coup je vous invite à assister un
match incroyable vu comme feuilleter
donc prenez du bon score et si on
préfère les céréales à ça c'est fait
alors je m'excuse d'avancé pour les
qualités nos voix bon c'est pas trop
dégueu quand même mais c'est vrai que
c'est moins bien que micro que j'ai là
c'est simplement que j'ai dû faire avec
les moyens du bord en tout cas ça son
relais van sant mars à des fous rires et
ça fait les cons c'est parti je vous
souhaite une très bonne vidéo
bon visionnage
sur ce total votre nom vous dit ça quand
on sait que laisse entendre c'est
pourquoi faire ça juste tellement à
l'air las et une armoire
superior tricorps tort
retour en images
en passant passant de 7 secondes oui
millions
attention il coupe ça ça me plait pas à
tout pour 2 0 ont même été plus doux
partout c'est matthieu homs at-il pas
vers le haut alors c'est moi qui rebonds
voilà non mais sérieux mais ça va
on apprend tout la section pêche
illicite et attend reprise nom change de
musiciens jouant des questions je suis
là attention pas ses mots c'est que ce
soit celle de miller tabak & co
non
lola était mort
ces gens les a pas gagnés quand tu vois
ça allait pensait-on fait des gros noms
oui merci petit montbard au moins
aujourd'hui
merci c'est la lente non
hu à présent c'est beaucoup moins c'est
petit c'est non c'est vrai ça ici est
simple oui c'est ça m
là ils descendent des biens des classes
l'après par trop bas oui ça fait très
beau et cuba
c'est juste que leur donner de l'espace
à lui parler non j'étais reparti à la
hausse
là tu dois m j'ai trouvé dans ce groupe
merde
ouais on rêver
ouais mais hélas hélas assez bon on
s'admire du moulin blanc devra lancer
tél
wen
ouais
[ __ ] mais allez on oublie les secours
ont battu ce faire la fête et là autour
d'eux les serviettes
pour ceux qui préfèrent on a même des
trous parce qu'enfin c'est le même topo
vous avez conclu jeu de mots